today's video is brought to you by
myheritage an incredible way to build
your family tree and discover your
origins more about them in just a bit
julius caesar spartacus sula marcus
crassus all of these men have had a
tremendous impact on the history of rome
and we've done bios on all of them and
each time we mentioned another man who
in turn had a great influence on their
own lives and careers pompeii he was
arguably the most successful military
leader that rome had ever known and
today we're giving him his due it's time
for the man himself to take center stage
in a special extended two-part
biographic series as we look at the life
and the career of pompeii the great
pompei was born nias pompeus magnus on
september 29 106 bc in the region
of python he was part of a family that
was in the midst of a quick climb up
rome social ladder just a few decades
earlier the name jen's pompeia would
have meant nothing to the average roman
they were after all plebeians meaning
that they were free romans but not part
of the elite patrician class basically
they were just commoners but in 141 bc a
man named quintus pompeos became the
first family member to receive a
consulship this opened the door for
other pompeians to attain important
political officers as well as fill up
the family coffers consequently by the
time pompei was born his father neues
pompeous strabo was among the richest
men in python that being said it appears
that strabo was not a popular man quite
the opposite in fact playtalk noted that
when strabo died seemingly after being
struck by a thunderbolt people took the
body from the funeral pyre and dragged
it through the streets while throwing
stones and hurling insults at it so
yeah not exactly a man of the people
which put him in stark contrast with
pompeii in fact the same plutarch
mentions that never in roman history had
there ever been a bigger gulf between
father and son in terms of how much the
people hated one and loved the other the
historian simply fawns over pompeii as
if you are the president of his fan club
here's what he says no roman ever
enjoyed heartier goodwill on the part of
his countrymen or one which began sooner
or reached a greater height in his
prosperity or remained more constant in
his adversity than pompey did there were
many reasons for the love bestowed on
pompeii his modest and temperate way of
living his training in the arts of war
his persuasive speech his trustworthy
character and his tact in meeting people
so that no man asked a favor with less
offense or bestowed one with a better
men for in addition to his other graces
he had the art of giving without
arrogance and of receiving without loss
of dignity that's just one paragraph
there is more but we don't have time for
the whole love fest today suffice to say
that pompeii was a popular dude with the
people now we've probably mentioned this
before but it is worth repeating barring
extraordinary examples such as today's
subject the romans had a pretty standard
sequence for the men of the upper
classes to advance their careers it was
called the cursus honorum and it started
with the office of crester and ideally
it ended with the position of console
before that though it was expected that
the men would serve in the military so
that meant that that was pompeii's first
stop he joined his father's command
around 90 bc and fought in the social
war this was not one of rome's more
famous conflicts but it was an important
one nonetheless because it led to the
complete romanization of italy basically
back then rome was the dominant power in
italy but it didn't control all of it
yet it had multiple allies in the region
known as saki but they were unhappy that
they weren't granted the same rights as
citizens of rome so in 91 bc they went
to war the fighting went on for four
years and even though rome won the soggy
ultimately got what they wanted as they
were granted roman citizenship in order
to avoid similar conflicts in the future
strabo obtained his biggest moment of
glory at the battle of ascalon in 89 bc
and before this he was celebrated on the
streets of rome with a triumph and was
named consul for that year as far as
pompei was concerned it was a bit too
early for him to shine as a soldier
however in 87 bc once his father died
and he inherited the family estate that
became a different matter entirely
pompeii didn't have to wait too long to
put his burgeoning military prowess to
good use because in 84 bc rome became
embroiled in its fiercest power struggle
yet known as sulla's civil war
[Music]
now we've already talked about solar
here on biographics so if you want the
full picture of that conflict you can
give that video a quick watch basically
rome was in the grips of a civil war
between two factions one led by sulla
and the other by gaius marius and lucius
cornelius sinner pretty early on into
the war it became evident that this
wasn't the kind of conflict where other
romans could just stick their heads in
the sand and wait for it to blow over
everyone had to choose a side or it
would be chosen for them for pompeii the
decision was fairly easy since he bore a
grudge against sinner referring back to
godor plutarch again the historian said
the young pompei escaped an
assassination attempt engineered by
sinner when campaigning with his father
this was after sinner supposedly bribed
a man named lucius torrentius to stab
pompeii while he was sleeping in his
tent given that gas marius died early
during the civil war and sooner became
the leader of his faction it's no
surprise that pompeii decided to throw
his lot in with sulla but he almost
didn't get the chance to do it as he
nearly lost everything at the outset of
the wall when the marius cinefaction
took over rome they began enacting
proscriptions those that were found
guilty were declared outlaws they had
their properties confiscated and most
were also executed just for good measure
at first they did this solely to the
supporters of sula but they generously
expanded their program to include many
other romans whose wealth they coveted
and pompeii soon counted himself among
those wretched souls accused of stealing
some of the booty from the battle of
asculum if he would be found guilty his
property would be confiscated and he
would be lucky to escape with his life
but that's not what happened instead he
managed to prove that a freed man in his
father's employ was the true booty thief
that plus his natural charms managed to
sway the magistrates who found him
innocent he even married the judge's
daughter and to steer the first of his
five wives realistically pompey probably
escaped with his life and his wealth
intact because his enemies didn't
perceive the young and experienced
soldier as
much of a threat even so pompey
definitely knew not to attempt to pay so
he quickly left rome and retreated to
paison there he seemingly fell off the
grid for the next few years but what
pompe was really doing was quietly
recruiting troops and waiting for the
right time to strike and that time came
in 83 bc when sulla and his army began
marching on rome this was the point of
no return for pompeii once he aligned
himself with sula he intertwined their
fate either both men ended up rich and
powerful beyond their wildest dreams or
they both got their heads chopped off
and mounted on pikes both
good options but let's just say pompey
probably preferred the first one and
it's not like he was the only one taking
this gamble another name you'll probably
recognize marcus crassus also allied
himself with sulla as did another
influential roman general named mattelus
pires without a doubt pompeii was the
youngest and least experienced in that
group but he had two things going for
him first he had the money to equip and
train all of the troops and second he
was just so damn likable and charismatic
you think that this might not matter so
much this was after all war and not a
talent show competition but the reality
was that both sides were in full-on
recruitment mode and every man pompei
enticed to his side meant fewer soldiers
fighting for his enemy it is said that
pompeii started out with only one legion
when he left paison but had amassed
three legions by the time he actually
entered battle and speaking of which
let's get to that fighting like guys
marius sinner had also died by this
point and a guy named cabo was running
the show before joining with sula pompei
scored three quick and surprising
victories against three of cabo's
generals wenzilla heard of this he raced
to meet this young upstart and when the
two finally met pompey hailed sulla as
imperator in return sula got off his
horse took off his helmet and returned
the same greeting and this was a massive
show of respect on behalf of the
experienced veteran sulla who more or
less made it clear to everyone that the
23 year old
was now his protege and to be fair
pompey paid off this trust in spades
after meeting with sulla he left for
gaul where he provided reinforcements
but metallus he wasn't present at the
decisive battle of the choline gate
which won solar the civil war but it was
then tasked by sulla with chasing down
the remaining opposition so that they
would not be able to raise new armies
and reignite the conflict this included
cabo himself who abandoned rome once he
knew the war was lost he intended to
retreat to africa to gather new troops
but he only made it as far as sicily
before pompeii caught up to him captured
him and had him executed pompey then
crossed the mediterranean into africa
and was successful in crushing the last
remnants of the marius in a faction at
the battle of utica in 81 bc once his
task was complete it was time for
pompeii to go back to rome and enjoy his
spoils of war
so you ever wondered where you come from
who are your relatives a few generations
removed are what they did where they
lived well with myheritage the sponsor
of today's video prepare to shine a
light on your past and learn something
amazing but personally i'm not someone
who knew a ton about where they came
from just vague stories from parents and
grandparents but not a lot of really
concrete stuff so having my heritage has
been amazing to add some details to
those rather vague stories an example
well as a kid my nan often talked about
how her father my great-grandfather was
an early pilot in the raf the royal air
force in world war one and you kind of
never know with stories like that well
what exactly is the hard truth what is
embellished well thanks to my heritage i
dived into all of that and i found out
that my great-granddad was in the raf he
was a lieutenant and i found these
handwritten records of him doing this
stuff and medals and all of this and he
was the part of these bombing runs into
europe which was pretty crazy even
cooler my heritage found a picture of
him posing in uniform as a young man it
was all kind of grainy but they have
this cool tool which enhances photos and
at first i was like why is this zooming
in hearts please but uh technology has
apparently come some way because it took
this great photo and it made it amazing
on screen now not even joking you can
also colorize photos animate them if you
want to the tools really are pretty
incredible my heritage has over 18
billion records so it's not exactly a
surprise that i found some stuff about
me and it is the number one family
history service in europe they make it
super easy to build a family tree going
back many generations i got back as far
as the 1850s so far so click the link
below you'll get a 14 day free trial to
enjoy all the amazing features
myheritage has to offer if you decide to
continue your subscription you'll get a
50 discount and now back to today's
video
the streets of rome were flooded with
cheers and exaltations as pompeii made
his triumphant return not to be outdone
by the common rabble sula greeted his
protege with the name pompeous magnus
pope the great the title that he would
use from then on silver also arranged
for the young general to divorce his
first wife and marry his stepdaughter
amelia who died during a miscarriage
less than a year later and of course
along with the respect and power pompe
was also granted untold wealth like
marius and sinner before him solar
enacted prescriptions on his political
enemies and allowed his closest allies
to do pretty much whatever they wanted
in order to enrich themselves it didn't
take long for all of this success to go
to pompeii's head he was still in his
mid-20s and already one of the richest
and most powerful men in rome and he
felt like showing off nowadays he'd
probably post pictures of himself in his
private jet on social media but pompeii
wanted the first century version of an
insta brag a triumph through the city
streets sulla balked at the idea nobody
as young as pompeii had ever celebrated
such an honor according to roman law
only a consul or a pray till might
receive a triumph and pompeii who had
scarcely grown a beard as yet wasn't old
enough to even become a senator but hey
silla initiated a civil war and declared
himself dictators so who was he to give
lectures on roman traditions despite
many protestations from other officials
sulla relented and pompeo was given his
triumph but this little vanity project
it didn't exactly go according to plan
instead of having his chariot pulled by
horses through the streets pompeii
wanted it drawn by four elephants that
he brought back from africa except he
didn't realize that the elephants would
be too wide to fit through the city
gates so right at the beginning of the
triumph the procession had to stop
outside of rome and have the elephant
swapped with horses all while pompeii
sat in his chariot waving at everyone
like an idiot and pretending that
nothing was wrong but despite occasional
missteps pompeii's reputation flourished
if there was one thing that could endear
someone to all the classes of rome it
was military glory and so far pompeii
had a spotless record but his meteoric
rise rubbed some people the wrong way
including sulla who began resenting his
young disciple tensions between the two
increased over a man named marcus
emelius lepidus schuller hated him and
called him the worst of men pompe for
whatever reason not only liked him but
publicly campaigned for lepidus to be
appointed consul the deterioration of
the relationship between mentor and
protege became evident after sula's
death in 78 bc because he completely
snubbed pompei in his will even though
he bequeathed gifts to his other friends
furthermore sula delivered a final i
told you so from beyond the grave
because that same year lepidus was named
consul and then tried to stage his own
rebellion and take over power by force
he was joined by sinner the younger the
son of the man who fought against sulla
as well as marcus junius brutus the
father of caesar's future assassin in
fact lebanese also asked a young
up-and-coming julius caesar to join his
uprising but he wisely decided to stay
out of this one probably civil wars just
weren't his thing anyway lepidus's main
rival was a man named catalyst the other
console it's worth reminding everyone
that the roman republic always had two
consoles at the same time so that no man
could gain absolute power although it
certainly didn't stop them from trying
but catalyst wasn't exactly praised for
his unparalleled military genius so the
senate was hoping that pompeii might
lend a hand as well unfortunately for
him he did despite his previously
hardened support of lepidus pompey did
his mayor culpa and rallied against him
he was sent to mutina in gaul which was
lepidus neck of the woods to lay siege
on brutus that way assuming cattlers
would also be victorious labradors would
be left with nowhere to retreat and
regroup pompe's siege was lengthy but
successful and upon capturing brutus he
quickly had him executed even though the
latter had surrendered this wasn't the
first time that pompey had one of his
opponents killed under
let's just say iffy circumstances cabo
had suffered the same fate and his death
earned pompe the anonymous moniker of
adlocentlus carnifex the teenage butcher
meanwhile catalyst also achieved his
goal and defeated lepidus at the battle
of the milvian bridge although his
victory wasn't decisive enough to
completely negate lepidus as a threat
once again pompeii the closer was sent
in to obtain a more permanent result
which he got
sort of he defeated lebanese in battle
but the latter was still able to escape
and flee to sardinia where he fell ill
and died so
well mission accomplished
already pompey had amassed an impressive
military resume many other commanders
would have used all of that stockpiled
glory to parlay it into a safe cushy
position as a senator a governor maybe
even a consul in fact that's exactly
what catalyst was hoping pompe would do
given the last decade or so where rome
saw conflict after conflict right
outside at city gates any military
leader with command of a loyal army was
cause for concern after all who knows
what ideas pompeii might get that's why
catalyst told him to pay his soldiers
disband his army and return to rome
where he could be properly feasted for
his victory as it turns out catalyst was
right to be concerned because pompeii
did not want to disband his army it
appears that glory in battle tasted much
sweeter to him than even the most
sumptuous roman banquet but at the same
time he wasn't so gung-ho that he was
willing to make an enemy of the senate
so he searched for a compromise by
seeking out another conflict where his
services might be needed and he found it
in the iberian peninsula or hispania as
the romans called it that region was
under the hegemony of a general called
quintus satorius a former ally of sinner
and marius satorius packed up his bags
and retreated to espana when his side
lost the civil war there he found allies
in some of the local liberian tribes and
made himself the de facto ruler of the
peninsula ever since then rome had been
trying to retake control of the region
but had failed to do so granted it
didn't allocate a lot of resources to
the problem since lepidus was more of a
pressing issue but satorius also proved
himself quite adept at doing a lot with
a little since he was usually outmanned
now gunned he often resorted to guerilla
warfare to disable his enemies and
prevent a pitched battle from happening
this strategy worked for years in fact
when pompei got in on the action
satorius was already successfully
foiling pompeii's former military ally
metellus pires the reality of pompei's
actions was again iffy since he
disobeyed nord from catalyst and kept
coming up with excuses to not disband
his army he was relying on his
supporters in the senate particularly a
senator named lucius philippus as well
as others who realized that they needed
pompei regardless of their feelings
towards him philippus even suggested
that pompeii be given the authority of a
pro-consul referring to a military or
administrative leader who was given
powers outside of a regular term
traditionally only men who had
previously served as consoles could be
made pro-consuls pompeii meanwhile had
never held the position of crystal the
first stop on the cursor sonorum however
as we saw with his military triumph its
first military triumph we should specify
pompeii was an extraordinary man one for
whom the standard rules simply did not
apply pompey arrived in hispania in the
spring of 76 bc this would be his home
for the next five years as sartorius
would prove to be his biggest challenge
yet in fact pompeii started off his part
in the satorian war as it was known with
a very inauspicious and rare event a
defeat in battle at the siege of laurel
and it wasn't due to being outnumbered
or some natural disaster either on that
day sartorius was simply the better
general he allowed his opponent to think
he had the upper hand when in fact he
was falling for an ambush the young
cocky pompei realized too late that his
men were marching into a trap and by
that point there was nothing he could do
but watch up to 10 000 of his soldiers
get slaughtered by sartorius forces the
shocking outcome left pompe reeling some
of the shine came off the golden boy who
up until that point seemed like he could
do no wrong but he made a comeback
following year sartorius mistake was
thinking that pompeii was a beaten man
he left him to his underlings while
sartorius himself went to deal with
metalis but the pompeii of old returned
at the battle of valentia in 75 bc and
he not only defeated tutorials as
generals but also inflicted massive
losses on their armies thus compensating
for his shameful performance at leron
the next time he fought stories in
battle was at the battle of sucrow and
then the battle of sagundam that same
year both ended in stalemates afterwards
satorius decided to retreat into the
mountains regroup his forces and resume
his guerrilla tactics by attacking
supply lines and scouting parties at the
same time pompeii's side was starting to
run thin on troops and resources so he
sent word to rome to ask for money
supplies and reinforcements since both
camps were in rebuilding mode the next
few years were pretty quiet with only
the occasional skirmish breaking up the
monotony this was fine for pompeii but
sartorius was dealing with in-house
problems low morale defections conflicts
between romans and iberians all spurred
on by one of his generals marcus papurna
who coveted the top spot for himself
ultimately it was treachery and hubris
that ended the satorian war papuana and
his co-conspirators assassinated
satorius at a feast in 73 bc a mistake
that would shortly bring on their own
demise for whatever reason paper assumed
that things would magically get better
with him in charge but it was quite the
opposite since papuana was destined to
be robin to satorious as batman he just
didn't have the charisma the experience
or the skill to be an effective leader
many of his troops abandoned him either
defecting to the other side or simply
going home when metal has heard that
satorius was dead he was confident that
pompeii could handle the remnants of his
army so he returned to rome the latter
indeed proved up to the task using a
simple decoy tactic to lure paper nia's
troops into the open and then crushing
them in an ambush papernia and most of
his officers were captured and summarily
executed as per pompei's regular modus
operandi he still had to spend some time
taking care of stragglers but pompeii
had won the satorian war he was getting
ready to return to rome where he would
undoubtedly enjoy another triumph when
he received words that an escaped
gladiator was causing chaos throughout
italy not one to pass up a good fight
pompeii had found his next opponent
spartacus but we'll talk about that when
we pick up the story in part two
the wrath of pompeii so subscribe and
stay tuned
[Music]
you